it's tuesday my dudes
and you know what that means cringe
tuesday time
yeah tuesdays is tuesday
that's right everyone and today we're
looking at probably a video that a lot
of you have already seen
i'm probably one of the last commentary
channels i guess that's what i am
to comment on this but it's just
too good to be true
morgs pass videos
guys what did you say to me what do you
say to me you wanna
you wanna get a glasgow kiss now
morgue's kind of disappeared for a while
i don't know if you're familiar with
this
uh kid but he came back he came back
with his family
and it's just it's just weird boys he's
been outside
all day
you don't have to do anything so the
gist of these videos
is that you can pause someone with a
remote control
at any time now what the rules are
beyond that it's never explained
who has the controller how long do you
get to use a controller
can you pause anyone at any i don't i
need to know the rules otherwise how the
freak am i supposed to understand
but all you need to know is of course
challenge i'm the winner yeah the mom
really likes to make that face and it
makes me very very very very
very very uncomfortable there's ten
thousand dollars on the line
it's like the perfect example of youtube
these days you can't do anything
well there's not ten thousand dollars on
the line well why should i care then huh
why should i hear before we start guys
if you want to win a brand new iphone
you can't start a video without a
giveaway first
this is 2019 god damn it what we gotta
do
is subscribe to the channel yeah because
liking doesn't do anything you just have
to subscribe
and then after the video click the link
in the description for extra
entries oh morgan we get it from
talking about iphones where is the
iphone i want one
don't pause i don't understand what just
happened did he get the iphone
what is happening
that's what i like most about these
videos this is a super thick accent
no morgan no
for some reason they're all just yelling
constantly i don't understand how
everyone in this family is deaf
apparently
hey mom what are you up to i'm just
dying
morgan of course i'm your dino morgan
as usual wait a second morgan why have
you got your camera no
no no no see she always does that face
and i don't like it
i don't like it no morgan
what a beautiful face to pause on
what am i watching here like what is
this i don't i don't understand
i don't want to watch this anymore wait
a second
i really see editing it's like
hyper dramatic background music every
time
it's like i had brush in every single
one of my videos okay guys
i mean i guess this is literally me in
2013. i can't really beat too harsh
whatever you're hiding because it's
about to be burned
by the looks of it i think your
ironing is done
why are you laughing damn that's some
cruel anime laugh
mugs it's your t-shirt all along
morgan you made one mistake you forgot
to check whose church
it is well it's not yours and there's
only one other man so it must be mine
morgan it's not just any old shirt it's
your brand new
blackout mg7 not the a brand new
blackout ngc
merch
and that now me my new mgz blackout
merch right
not the new mg said blackout merch stop
making that seriously i can't
are you sure about that morgan guys it's
not the best way to celebrate
[Music]
jesus christ but at least you guys can
still cop it right now from mogs.com
just make sure you keep your items away
oh god don't zoom in on that oh god the
cold sore ugh
why would you in the nails do like dude
take care of your nails
from a brother from another you gotta
get those nails manicured brother
come on man come on marks
you gotta get your nails checked
look at those nails we better unpause
those nails if you know what i'm
gonna do limited edition and only
available for
seven days next saturday this is gonna
be gone forever
gone forever are you serious he's using
this marketing employee of
oh he's gonna be gone forever only seven
days that is
shameful how could he do that you know
some people just
turn their videos into one giant
advertising campaign
that's just sad and that's honestly just
shameful guys go to mogs.com
link in description do you think they
talk like this all the time or it's like
okay now we need to shoot this for you
all right okay so do you understand here
okay so what was my line check out the
merch
guys
hey kara good morning what are you up to
she's making new juice guys just making
juice just like when i pour milk out of
the cartridge i'm just making milk i
don't know what to tell you
oh no no
i like how she's barefoot for this as
well i mean
i can't shave it i do the exact same
thing you want to do something annoying
you always set it up like oh yeah
i should probably remove my socks oh
yeah we should probably shoot this
on the floor that's easy to clean up i
don't know how to tell you this guys i
know this might come as a shock
but this is fake all right if you point
the remote at someone and say
pause it doesn't actually work
okay
oh my gosh oh my gosh
oh my gosh
[Music]
you know the only thing this video is
really missing to fit
any sort of cliche is fortnite i'm still
thinking about how to eliminate kira and
mum
but in the meantime bro
let's play some fortnight wow look at
this guys it feels like it has been
ages since i've been on fortnight we're
only five minutes in
guys i'm running away i'm running away
i'm getting chased
oh my freaking god this is a gamer
moment don't
don't do it more
you just got me eliminated
anyway morgan i've had my fun on calls
hope you win bro
this next clip is me every time i lose
in a video game i demand that you say
sorry for making me lose
my game this is completely and utterly
on
what am i watching
this is just a normal scenario for those
of you who don't know what it's like
if a girlfriend interrupts you in a
video game i have the exact same
reaction she went too far
i demand that you say sorry for making
me lose at my game this is completely
and utterly fun this is literally the
first time i've ever seen you
on the treadmill well i went on once
with
[Applause]
how is she being careful not to fall off
it'd be a shame if you got
paused no morgan no
no oh
yeah let's watch that again oh
yeah again okay
[Music]
this is so awkward i can imagine filming
this with my mom
just have your mom laying there on the
floor
what did you do i like how they went
through all this
and then they thought hey let's that was
awesome we replayed the clip three times
but we should do it again
[Music]
i'm getting back up she's getting back
on she's getting back on
that distract me from a workout
pause
oh wow
that was just how she was running she's
right she was running like this
dude her hand looks like a freaking bird
bird morix hands mom
confirmed
oh now she's dead okay guys
oh my god i thought for once they
wouldn't scream jesus christ
god damn it humiliated for the last time
because of morgan i've got a shoulder
injury i can barely hold the camera
i have a plan to get morgan back and
kyra's not safe either
don't say i didn't warn you oh no what's
the matter
oh
does she call her her husband bald
martin that's awesome
i think he just docks himself as well
can you imagine being neighbors to this
family
bye i guess actually
it's probably not worse than being
neighboring me you'd want a bag of eyes
[Music]
joke's over unpause me
uncles
yeah oh my god it's not like you could
have done that anyway
why do i care it doesn't matter it's
[Music]
oh my god she got destroyed that's some
pause action right there
that's what you get for killing him in
fortnite
these girlfriends gotta learn
i like how now after they've done the
groceries they had their food
they come back and they thought to
themself in the car hey wouldn't it be
epic if we like pause in the car
since you humiliated me in the shop
morgan no
morgan no don't do this morgan it's
crazy no morgan
pause oh my god oh god
you can't do that if she crashes we
crash with her we're in the car
[Laughter]
oh my god morgan you can't do that if
she dies
we die because we are in the car we're
all sitting in this car together
so if she crashes then we all crash
i think morgan you can't do that
morgan i bet you weren't expecting
mealworms on your head
these are the stinkiest bugs i could
find and honestly i don't even know what
i i've eaten those they're not that bad
they're like dried out they don't
i'm just saying it's not that bad okay
i've had live ones on scare pewdiepie
season one that's gross okay this is
nothing shaking my head you call this a
pause challenge
mail worm is but um and also
is no one gonna point out that they're
not actually pressing the pause button
they're just pressing the off button
okay see that's not the post button
all right so i think that finally
confirms
that the pause challenge is actually in
fact fake
once and for all leave your comments
down below what you think
is it real it like how are they doing
this
kill yeah yeah what yeah what is this
what is ew
yeah ew
boss hey morgan i think you're having a
nice
walk did his mom just walking i mean
naked in the shower
no one sees a problem with this you look
fancy
straightening your hair and everything
you never straighten your hair you mean
i always look good
stop bouncing me well keira i'm sorry
about this i
didn't want to have to do this but after
what you've just done to me i have no
other choice bruh just stop please
please please
please please stop please welcome okay
we've been messing around i'm really
sorry but you can just warm yourself up
off
no no excuses you got morgs killed in
fortnite you went too
far you now you pay consequence this is
like a physical thing
it's gonna really look bad well but once
it burns off it's gonna take months to
grow back please stop kira i'm gonna sit
here
all day until the hair burns off
the only way you can stop me is by
giving up
you've made me do this i can't do it i
can't do any more morgan please please
just
stumble with me i i'm gonna have to give
up you know how much females care about
their hair morgan
kara i'm not gonna unpause you
oh my god morgan fine finally give up i
give up okay more than fine i can't do
it
no like he didn't burn up it was just
cut off
and the music do it as well
i think one thing's for sure martin is
not gonna give up so i forfeit
so he forfeits i guess all right that's
cool i'm really glad i watched this this
is a journey
to say the least uh i mean i'm in front
of morse before
he clearly doesn't care it's just really
weird seeing a whole family do this
at the same time it's clearly just like
a kids show at this point
it's weird to me seeing how these things
are still happening on youtube
and doing very successfully at it i mean
21 million views that's
well done what can i say family friendly
pg clean
uh okay well how do you explain this huh
i feel so bad for martin like if you
agree his facial expressions are
hilarious
so people are actually watching it all
right fair enough to you
what can i say that's it for cringe week
let me know what you want next time
and as always smile and happy what you
never played two for simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price